[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en images une nature
luxuriante les espèces endémiques les
forêts réunionnaises sont riches de
cette biodiversité pour la journée
internationale des forêts ces jeunes
accompagnés par des agents de louer nef
ont pu appréhender et comprendre la
fragilité de ces espaces personnellement
ça nous permet de sortir le dimanche 2-2
s'aérer l'esprit un peu et de
d'apprendre des choses sur la nature
c'est un moyen de s'évader un moyen de
vivre avec la nature les oiseaux les
espèces endémiques
donc ça sert à apprendre un peu de
liberté en fait ce départ on possède 95
60 des forêts réunionnaises et s'en
occupe il s'en préoccupent et au
quotidien et mais aussi dans son budget
20 millions d'euros pour protéger
restaurer sauvegarde et sensibiliser
pour une gestion durable de ses forêts
de nos forêts donc qu'elles ne
participent à cette journée et c'est
indispensable
traverser à pied la plaine du volcan le
piton textor et redescendre vers la
forêt de mare longue c'est le parcours
retenu pour cette septième édition de la
caldeira trail 700 coureurs étaient au
départ de cette traversée magique au
coeur de la réunion
[Musique]
165 m cet espoir que je connais mieux le
parti a la sensation est facile à
festieux se réveille sous le soleil
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé je décide d'être
la femme libre et intelligente qui ne
sert pas qu'à cuisiner faire le ménage
les 13 finalistes du premier concours
régional d'éloquence se sont exprimés
sur la scène du théâtre plein air de
saint-gilles pendant six à dix minutes
ces jeunes se sont exprimés sur le thème
de la violence intrafamiliale
je rêve d'une société où les femmes
prennent de plus en plus de décisions
politiques
je rêve d'une société le salaire des
peurs et celui des hommes est égal c'est
vraiment un honneur que d'être parmi
vous et participer à ce jury pour le
concours de l'éloquence le conseil
départemental quelque part près par ces
jeunes à ce concours d'éloquence et on a
le plaisir d'avoir avec nous ce soir un
jeune conseiller départemental des
jeunes qui justement a pris l'or qui
s'est présentée pour être président il
ya posé sa candidature pour être
présidente des conflits jeunes du
département
[Musique]
le bonus de cette semaine ce sont les
images de la bande annonce de la série
les réunionnais formidable la saison 2
commencera très prochainement sur 9 7 4
[Musique]